[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
not going to fight your war
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
aren't you the cutest little thing
aren't you
what's your name hey everybody it's
Charlie so we're all still freaking out
about the Captain Marvel trailer but we
need to talk about the post-credits
scene Avengers four and what Kevin Feige
and the Russos have been saying about
her character as well as what's going on
in the MCU during phase four there's a
new round of that imax ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Captain Marvel moment on the video
standard procedure for Marvel movies is
that there's multiple post credits
scenes guardians of the galaxy 2 is the
only exception because they were like 5
post credits scenes but usually it's two
or three scenes typically there's one
that just pays off a moment that they
set up earlier in the film it could be a
joke or it could be a reference to
something that a character said like
when they give cracklin yondu's new fin
like it's an emotional payoff but it's
kind of just a funny moment that's
specific to something that they did
during guardians 2 there's usually
another scene that's a direct set up to
the sequel of that specific movie so
like we're talking about the Captain
Marvel movie they'll be like a scene
that will set up Captain Marvel to
whatever they're gonna call that then
usually all Marvel films have some
moment that sets up the next direct MCU
movie in a really big way so that's
where our Captain Marvel Avengers for
post-credit scene happens where they pay
off Nick Fury's page we have a pretty
good idea of what some of those moments
are probably going to be so during the
trailer annette bening tells Captain
Marvel that they remade her she was
reborn as one of them bigger better
stronger faster more powerful and that
she would live longer also that she
could be a grand warrior hero for the
Kree Empire and helped them win the
kree-skrull war that had lasted for a
thousand years they don't tell you that
during the trailer but this is a never
ending war with the scrolls that has
been going on for eons so it's the war
to end all wars at least at that time
obviously they haven't got to Thea knows
with the Infinity Gauntlet or anything
like that so things do get much worse
but at that moment it's a war that's
been going on for so long that it's just
become a big part of their culture that
they grow up to become warriors so that
they can fight in the war to get married
have children so that those children can
then grow up and fight in the war - it
looks like she's showing her here what
looks like a giant map of the Kree
Empire probably explaining the
kree-skrull war to her
it kind of comes off like that big
PowerPoint tutorial that ego the Living
Planet gave to Peter quill during
guardians of the galaxy - he called that
the explainer scene in movies where a
character explains really cosmic history
or complex mythology or backstory
necessary to get all the non comic-book
readers up to speed so they can
understand what's happening during the
movie like why are they fighting why the
scrolls evil how come this Wars been
going on for so long why is it so
important that I fight in this so that's
usually why they have scenes like this
where person like Captain Marvel doesn't
know anything and says could you explain
this to me but really they're doing that
for the benefit of the audience the
trailer presents
Annette Bening like she's some really
important figure of authority and
because she's such a really big actress
in Hollywood it feels like a Kurt
Russell ego the Living Planet type of
casting where you get a really famous
actress to play a super Jeep cut
important character so like even if you
don't care about Annette Bening if
you're a big comic book fan you'll
probably care about who she's playing so
I do like the theory that she's playing
the MCU version of the Kree supreme
intelligence which would technically
make her a villain because the supreme
intelligence is this really cool
calculating entity that doesn't really
care about morality or collateral damage
it's singular goal is the supremacy in
advancement of the Kree Empire so like
look at the smile on her face that just
feels real a sinister almost everyone
thought after that Avengers infinity war
post-credit scene in the ant-man and the
wasp post-credits scene that the quantum
realm would have something to do with
getting young twentysomething brie
larson Captain Marvel from 1990s MCU to
present-day Avengers for MCU after she
received her page from Nick Fury because
everyone's like that's a lot of times
she'd be in her 40s by the time Avengers
4 picks up like somehow time-travel
would have to be a factor I saw some
even weirder theories about the quantum
realm but last year Kevin Feige said
something really interesting about
Captain Marvel in general because people
are like where has she been the whole
time that all this stuff has been
happening where was she during the
original Avengers movie during age of
Ultron
where was she during infinity war so all
Kevin Feige had said was is he pointed
to the sky and said she's been out there
meaning that she's been in outer space
this whole time so that scene in the
trailer where we see Captain Marvel
declared that she's going to end the
kree-skrull war makes it sound like it's
going to happen in
stantly in the last 15 minutes of the
movie but think about it this way the
Korean the scrolls are enormous galactic
empires that span over many different
systems you're talking about whole
quadrants of the universe
so just because Captain Marvel blows up
a small fleet of ships doesn't mean that
all over the universe all Kree and all
Skrulls automatically just drop their
weapons and say oh you know what the war
that we've been fighting for a thousand
years we're just gonna stop that all
right now all at the same time so she
probably just winds up spending the next
20 years slowly flying all over Crees
Scrolls space ending the war and
policing that part of the universe to
make sure that it doesn't happen again
and because Annette Bening says she'll
live longer in 20 years when she gets
that page from Nick Fury she still
probably looks just as young as she does
in the 90s during the events of the
Captain Marvel movie so it's like a Thor
situation he's 1,500 years old but he
still looks like he's in his 30s maybe
some character during Avengers 4 will
make a joke about that like wow she
still looks pretty young for someone
who's in their 40s like I don't expect
them to get too deep into that loki made
a reference one time about Asgardians
living approximately 5000 years but like
you don't really hear people talking
about how old door is on a very regular
basis like he just gets referenced once
or twice across 22 films the other
post-credit scene or scenes multiple
scenes will probably be just setting up
Captain Marvel sequels in you know odds
are because we don't know how long it's
gonna be for them to make that guardians
of the galaxy three movie Captain Marvel
is our only real big space based
franchise for them to use to set up
other space based spin-offs we're
talking like the Nova movie or any other
potential things that they want to tease
because it's a little too early to do
Fox x-men's space based movie but a
couple years ago Kevin Feige did say
that they were developing a lot more
cosmic movies so stuff that was
happening in places other than planet
Earth but early prediction one
post-credit scene involves Captain
Marvel leaving earth again to go into
outer space to police the Kree in the
scrolls hopefully she takes her cat with
her but then there's probably a moment
where Nick Fury sees her off with his
one eye remember he's losing his eye
during the film something about how he's
gonna change his ways and be less
trusting of other people I do love the
new joke theory that people came up with
the trailer dropped last night that the
cat is gonna be the one to take Nick
Fury's eye out even though really I
think that it's gonna be Talos when he's
made to look like the SHIELD agent that
Nick Fury has been trusting this whole
time but you have a Nick Fury
post-credit scene moment because he's
such a big MCU character obviously he'll
have some sort of tag then early theory
elsewhere in deep space they'll set up a
super Skrull teaser because the super
scroll is a really big Marvel villain in
the comics and because they'll have all
this Fox x-men IP they will be able to
use that character I think previously
there was a Fox Marvel IP problem with
that but that won't be an issue in the
future and the Skrulls are gonna
continue to be a big villain race think
about them replacing the our es
just like blanket space-based villains
in the Marvel Universe
then maybe hopefully an OVA or a quasar
teaser like the quantum bands of quasar
but let me know in the comments assuming
there's two or three post-credit scenes
what do you want those to be I know a
lot of people are wondering about the
Avengers 4 trailer there's a rumor that
they're delaying it it was supposed to
drop on Wednesday but it might be
delayed because of President Bush's
funeral there was also a rumor that a
spider-man far from home trailer was
gonna drop later this week if they wind
up delaying the Avengers 4 trailer
they'll also probably delay the
spider-man far from home trailer but
whatever they do wind up hosting I will
totally make videos so no worries but
click here to rewatch the Captain Marvel
trailer and click here to learn about
everything the Russo's have given away
about Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]